[inaudible] [inaudible]
oh well,
welcome everyone.
I'm assuming that applause was not for me.
My name is Bill Flanagan and I'm the dean
of law here at Queen's University and
I am pleased to welcome all of you here
today for the inaugural liberty lecture,
generously sponsored by Greg [inaudible]
law 80 a long time and very generous
supporter of the law school and Greg is
here today and I just want to corrupt
the join me in thanking
Greg for sponsoring this
[inaudible] [inaudible].
The Liberty Lecture is intended to
explore the meaning of liberty in our
contemporary society,
a subject of rich
interest to philosophers,
political scientists,
and legal scholars.
Just to name a few.
And today's liberty lecture is moderated
by Professor Bruce Party to my right of
the Faculty of Law and
experts in a variety of areas,
including environmental law,
environmental law and governance,
ecosystem management,
climate change,
water law,
and university governance.
Our guest today is Dr. Jordan Peterson,
a professor of psychology at
the University of Toronto,
and a clinical psychologist.
His many publications include
his recently published book,
12 rules for life,
an antidote to chaos and his research
spans a number of topics including the
psychology of religion and the modern
understanding of creativity and
personality.
I know that today's lecture has generated
a great deal of interest as is evident
from the packed hall here today.
It's also generated a
certain amount of heat.
The proposed topic,
the rising tide of compelled speech in
Canada is for many a controversial one
and I know that many of you in the
audience will hold widely divergent views.
I fully support your opportunity to be
heard and should you wish challenge the
speakers to defend their positions.
I know that today's speakers likewise
share this conviction and we'll welcome
your comments and questions as might be
appropriate for a lecture series named
after liberty.
I believe it is also important for me
to affirm at the outset that the core
values of the Faculty of law end of
Queens University include academic freedom
and respectful dialogue among
those with differing views.
This includes providing our speakers
with the opportunity to be heard and
providing all of you with the
opportunity to respond in a respectful
environment,
free from any harassment or any
attempts to shut down the conversation.
So it is in this spirit of free and
respectful academic exchange that I'm
pleased to launch or
this new lecture series.
Welcome again and welcome to our guest
and I look forward to our discussion.
Thank you.
[inaudible].
Okay,
thank you bill.
Welcome and thank you for coming.
I would like to underline what bill said,
which is that this event would not
have happened without the initiative in
support of Greg kids asking you.
So Greg,
thank you very much
[inaudible]
as well.
Before we start,
I would like to thank some
people from the Faculty of Law,
Diane Butler at him,
Blake Galippo and Christina Julian for
their help in putting this together.
I would also like to
acknowledge the support,
help and generous assistance of
several people around the university.
Uh,
Lisa plater and event services,
David Patterson and the
campus security office.
Uh,
you have been professional,
helpful,
straightforward and I thank you
very much for making this possible.
I would also like to return to
being Flanagan's observation
about the importance
of this moment and to acknowledge
the role that both being Flanigan and
principal wolf have played in enhancing
the reputation of this university in
terms of its commitment to academic
freedom and academic debate.
They have
reflected an unflinching
commitment to those ideas.
As Principal Wolf said on his blog,
informed respectful debate
is central to academia.
And Gentlemen,
I salute your academic statesmanship.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
so
we're going to proceed as follows.
A the first thing I would like to say is
that in the hall behind you afterwards,
there will be some of
Jordan's books on sale.
12.
Um,
what,
what's the title again?
12 rules for like 12,
12 rules for like wanting
to get the 12 what it was,
right?
It's not,
that's not 12 steps.
It's 12 rules.
Right?
Um,
we are going to proceed as follows.
Jordan and I are going to have
a conversation for half an hour,
maybe 40 minutes and then we are going
to throw the floor open to questions.
We'll describe what kinds of questions
that you should ask later on when we get
to that stage,
but our topic is the rising tide
of compelled speech in Canada.
I am going to take just a couple of
minutes to give us some context and set it
up and then I'll ask Jordan
to tell us what he thinks.
You may have seen the CBC
production of the tutors.
The story of King Henry the eighth
in one episode,
the king has condemned
Thomas Moore to death
for refusing to say that the king
is the head of the Church of England
more isn't his cell awaiting execution.
A friend comes to him to plead with
him to say what it is the king wants to
hear.
Morris says he cannot do that for
he does not believe it to be true.
Yeah.
In exasperate
the friends says,
you don't have to believe it.
You just have to say it.
When your brain makes
that kind of calculation,
you know you are under
the thumb of a tyrant
and Thomas Moore lost his head.
The tide of compelled
speech in Canada is rising.
The Law Society of Ontario has introduced
a new policy that requires each lawyer
to develop a statement of Principles
which endorses and acknowledges an
obligation to promote certain values.
The Ontario Human Rights Commission
says that under the Human Rights Code,
failing to address somebody by their
preferred Pronoun will constitute
discrimination for which you may
be investigated and prosecuted.
The Elementary Teachers,
Federation of Ontario has
introduced new curriculum
to require teachers to teach elementary
students about white privilege
and the Federal Summer Jay Grants Program
requires applicants to attest to the
values,
but the government believes it.
Okay.
They don't have to believe it.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
that's pure narcissism at work.
By the way,
[inaudible]
you do to hijack hijacking event like
this that other people put time and effort
into and to use the civility of the crowd
and the civility of the organizers as
an excuse to blatantly yellow.
You're ill informed opinions is no
way to conduct a civil dialogue.
It's absolutely appalling.
The people who do that,
she'd be embarrassed.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I would also say that as
students and his faculty members,
you shouldn't put up with it.
There's no way that you should allow
people who are doing this to hijack your
educational opportunities and
to bend and twist the functions,
the structures of the university.
It's not a good thing.
Not In any way at all.
He would say that was a very
disgraceful display fundamentally.
So let's,
let's stick with it.
Why,
why do you think people
are afraid of free speech?
Well,
you know,
people develop an ideological view of the
world because they don't want to think
through things in real detail and they're
aided and embedded in that endeavor by
their pathological professors
who were feeding them.
Uh,
what would I say over simplified?
An oversimplified radical view
of the world in my estimation,
is fundamentally based in,
in resentment.
Not that there's no reason for say,
a left wing view of the world
and we can get to that later.
It's,
it's easy virtue.
You know,
you can stand up in front of 900 people
with your black card and your and your
screeching and you can,
you can declaim to the entire audience,
your fundamental moral superiority.
You can tell everyone at,
at once that they're all beneath you
and you're standing for the right thing.
And absolutely none of that is earned.
You know,
like,
what the hell?
What the hell was that?
There's no seriously man.
There's just,
it's just complete misbehavior.
It's embarrassing.
And the fact that the people who do
that don't have enough sense to go hide
their head in shame just tells you
how badly socialized they are and how
terribly educated they are.
And the thing is,
the thing that's so awful is that there
are professors and educators who promote
that.
They say,
well,
that's how you change the world.
It's like it is how you change the world,
but it's certainly not
how you make it better.
You make it worse.
Clearly,
you know,
there's no comfort and out
and there's nothing about it,
this impressive.
It's no,
it's no better in some sense than a two
year old having a tantrum on the floor.
It's a,
it shows as far as I'm concerned,
it approximate the same level
of psychosocial development.
So when the fact that that
this is happening continually,
universities is,
it's,
it truly makes me embarrassed to
be associated with the university.
And now I say that with great
displeasure because you know,
I've been working for great universities
for a very long time and the university
is an absolutely remarkable institution.
You know,
it's survived for a thousand years and,
and to see it,
to see it brought down by,
by people whose behavior would be out
of place at a four year old's birthday
party is,
is something something Bizible to behold.
So,
so what about the actions of government
now because it has government after all
that is the source of this compelled
speech as law as well as other ways in
which they seek to restrict speech.
But the compelled speech is the most
egregious form of violation of how well
tell us about that.
Well,
I've been trying,
I've been trying to sort
this out because you know,
if you're a clinician,
I would say one of the problems you
always have when you're dealing with
behavior that's gone astray is to
understand at what level of analysis you
should address it.
You know,
is it a theological problem?
Is it a philosophical problem?
Is it a psychological problem?
Is it social?
Is it economic?
These are very complicated questions.
Is it a trivial issue?
Is it an issue of rights?
Is it,
is it something else?
The people who put in the
bill see 16 for example,
and its associated legislation
make the claim that it's,
it's a legislative womb that's facilitated
by nothing but compassion and desire
to expand the domain of,
of,
of let's say,
of rights and freedoms.
And you know,
there's nothing wrong in principle
with expanding the domain of rights and
freedoms,
except of course for every right and
for every freedom there's an attendant
responsibility and obligation.
So you have to keep that in mind.
When I looked at bill [inaudible] 16
and the legislation that surrounded it,
especially that was written by the
Ontario Human Rights Commission,
the policies that surrounded it and
also the policies that gave rise to the
social justice tribunals named
social justice tribunals.
Appallingly enough that that that gave
rise to those tribunals in Ontario.
The things I read just
made my hair stand on end.
You know,
the social justice tribunals have the
right to place themselves outside of
legal,
out of outside of jurors
prudential precedence.
It's like,
what the hell is that?
It's really what you're
going to make the case.
The only way I think that you could
justify doing that is it if you torture
yourself into the ideological proposition
that English common law is somehow an
oppressive branch of the patriarchy,
and because of that you have every right
and even obligation to place yourself
outside of its structure of precedent.
But we don't want to.
Police are so outside of the structure
of precedent of English common law.
I can tell you that it's,
it's one of the supreme
achievements of the human race.
It's,
it's produced societies that are as free
and as productive as any societies have
ever been anywhere on the
planet and certainly are now
and to dare to state that
you would place yourself
outside of that precedent.
That's the sort of thing that
made my hair stand on end.
And there were other elements of the
policies that were equally reprehensible,
not least,
their complete incoherence of formulation.
You,
I couldn't understand some of it,
like I don't understand,
for example,
with regards to the gender,
uh,
propositions,
how it can be that you can be
anywhere on the gender spectrum,
which by the way,
it's not a spectrum technically and it
actually matters which words you use.
If you're writing law,
you can be anywhere or
nowhere on that spectrum.
Like I don't know what that means and I
don't believe that the people who wrote
it,
no,
what it means either and you don't write
things that you don't understand into
the damn law.
You don't do that because the law unfolds
in society and it tangles people up as
it unfolds.
And it's no joke when that happens.
So you'll be very,
very careful when you're writing law and
you certainly don't want to write law
to push forward your
ideological commitments,
especially in the face of precedent
because precedent is what keeps law from
degenerating into audiology essentially.
So and so.
And so,
you know,
Tamtam answer your question,
more,
more fundamentally,
I don't believe that this argument has
ever been about the rights of transgender
people.
I think that it's an attempt by the
radical left ideologues to push their
ideological agenda forward using,
using,
they're using attempts to
manipulate the linguistic domain.
And I'm not willing to seat the loot
linguistic domain because I don't think
there are any more,
anything more important
than the words that you use.
And then when the government says we,
you should start using these words.
You should start thinking hard about your
damn government because your words are
no different than your
thoughts and your thoughts.
Orient Yourself,
your thoughts orient you in the world.
And if someone who's going to tell
you what it is that you have to think,
then they're going to
disorient you in the world.
And I wouldn't recommend that because
there's lots of terrible things that can
happen to you.
And if you're disoriented,
you're going to run into a
very large number of them.
So that's how it looks to me.
So,
but,
but the
ideological context of this,
it seems like something has changed.
Yes.
Because if you think back decades earlier,
liberals were the
champions of free speech.
Yes.
It was the conservatives at
a certain moment in time,
who are the sensors,
you know,
they,
they sought to curb a
blasphemy and obscenity,
sedition and so on.
And the,
and the Liberals said,
no,
free speech is the way we want to go.
And yet today that has flipped a,
if you,
if you look back to what left leaning
officials and authorities and,
and,
and figures said,
lemme just give you one quote.
This is Samuel Gompers who is the founder
of the American Federation of Labor in
1886 he said this,
he said,
the freedom of speech has been granted
to the people in order that they may say
the things
which,
sorry.
Misquoted that have not been granted to
the people in order that they may say
the things which please and which
are based upon accepted thought.
But the right to say the things which
displease the right to say the things
which may convey the new
and yet unexpected thoughts.
The right to say things
even though they do a wrong.
Now that is not a sentiment now carried
on by the left and today what has
happened?
Well again I see that it's a
consequence of continued agitation,
agitation by I would say
a minority of of the left,
the radical left in particular.
And those are people who aren't Marxist
Slash Neo Marxist in their fundamental
ideological orientation and have joined
that in an unholy union with the worst
of French,
postmodernism and and they
push it ideological certainty.
And the thing that,
the thing that's really distressing
about that is that if you know anything
about the history of oppressed people,
let's say much as I hate to engage in
that particular form of dialogue under the
current conditions,
it's pretty obvious that it's
freedom of speech is freedom.
That's particularly important for
people who don't have anything else.
Right?
It's if you're supporting freedom of
speech are not supporting the status quo.
I mean,
just think about,
let's,
let's use the logic of the radical
leftists and assume that society is a
tyrannical hierarchy and the people at
the top have the upper hand in everything
including access to communication.
These people are not your friends.
No.
Mark my words.
Now it's the sounds of the
barbarians pounding out the gate.
Right?
Yeah.
That's all.
I'll tell you again,
that use of in Kuwait,
what would you call it in Kuwait
sensation is the best formulation of their
argument.
And there's not much difference between
knocking on the doors and knocking on
you.
So keep that in mind.
It's not a music,
there's nothing to it,
there's nothing for it.
The thing that's also quite appalling
is that there's no evidence whatsoever
that the people who are conducting these
protests know what it is that they're
protesting against.
You know,
I was in,
alright,
alright.
I was in the midst of a discussion and
attempting to make the case that it's
freedom of speech.
That's,
that is what people who
have nothing still have,
right.
So if you look at the tyrannical
structure of our society,
let's say the people at the top have
access to means of communication.
Everyone knows that it's the people at
the bottom who have the right to say what
they think,
however badly they say it,
that enables them to get a toe
hold into the system and to,
and to make their suffering known.
That's what freedom of speech is for.
And so like what's the
protest against that?
And I'll tell you,
you know the rowdy called
Neo Marxists types.
They speak the language of power and
that's what they're speaking right now.
And if you want to live in a world where
everyone speaks the language of power,
then just let them do what they're
doing and see what happens.
I wouldn't recommend it.
It's not a pretty rote.
And you're all in a position,
you're on a situation in your life now
where you have to make decisions about
this sorts of things.
Like is this the sort of institution
that you want this to be?
Nope.
One of the,
uh,
one of the
arguments against what you
said about the pronouns Yup.
Was that,
well,
after all,
all you're being asked to do is to
say something that is reasonable.
It's not unreasonable to address somebody
by the pronouns that they prefer.
And yet,
if you think of any kind of
speech which is prescribed,
imagine a statute that said people
shall use the words hello and please and
thank you in their conversations.
That statute is untenable.
Yes.
Because it now required there's
people to use certain words
in their conversations,
even if those words are
reasonable themselves.
So that is not the question.
And it was not your case.
You are making that using a
pronoun was unreasonable itself.
Do I have that correct?
Well,
yeah.
First of all,
there's a couple of things
I'd like to say about that.
No,
I looked up the process by which the
Ontario government formulated it's
legislation with regards to the pronouns
and the consultation process that you
used and the consultation
process was deeply flawed.
They contacted activists and say,
let's activists of the Trans Community.
Okay.
Well,
there's a couple of things
I'd like to say about that.
The first is there is no trans community,
right?
Trans people are as diverse
as any other group of people,
and to the idea that somehow
because of one of their attributes,
they constitute a homogenous group is a,
well,
you'd think that that
would be a false with dip,
the people who are concerned
about treating groups of
people adequately would be
loath to,
to put forward,
but even more importantly,
there's absolutely no evidence whatsoever
that the activist types are actually
representatives of any of the communities
that they hypothetically activate on
behalf of.
It's like they're not elected,
they're not appointed,
they don't pull,
they do this.
They say,
look,
here's a group.
It's a minority group and it's oppressed.
I'm a member of that group and
therefore I stand for the group.
It's like,
actually,
no,
you don't.
You don't stand for your group.
You maybe stand for yourself.
You know,
I don't stand for men and I don't
have to stand for white men.
I'm not,
I'm not entitled to speak on their behalf.
And so the idea that it's the trans
community that wanted this is a completely
unsustainable idea.
It's certainly unproven.
I've had like 40 letters from trans
people since I started to engage in this,
call it
chaotic battle.
The only one of them was mildly
critical of what I was doing.
All the other ones,
there aren't that many trans people,
you know.
So to get 40 letters is
actually quite a few.
I'm not saying that this
is a scientific Paul,
but it's at least as scientific as the
process by which the Ontario government
generated it's legislation and I'm not
okay
and I'm not generating legislation.
And what these people
said to a person was,
I didn't ask to be the newest whipping
boy for the radical postmodernists.
All it's done is made
my life more difficult.
You know,
that basic letter would say,
well,
I'm transitioning from one gender to the
other and it's very difficult and I'm
not sure that it's the right thing to do.
And this has made the
process spectacularly more
difficult on all fronts.
It's like these people don't speak for me.
And just because they say they do,
that doesn't mean they do.
And so the other thing that we seem to
have swallowed as a society is this crazy
notion that,
well,
first of all,
that we should be portioned up
into our different minority groups,
which I think is a return to tribalism,
an unbelievably dangerous,
I can't really think of anything
more dangerous than that.
And then we've swallowed the idea that
if you identify yourself as a member of a
minority group and then you
bring forward a grievance,
you have to be treated as if you're
a valid representative of that group.
It's like,
Whoa,
why in the world would we do that guilt?
I suppose maybe that's part of
it or I think it's mostly guilt.
You don't want to stand up and say,
well,
you know who died and
made you king so to speak.
You know?
And can we,
can we stay on that logic for a moment?
The the idea.
So this,
this compelled speech material seems
to insist upon treating people not as
individuals,
but as members of groups do either blame
them or to favor them as a member of a
group.
Like we take that logic and extended,
you know that the group identity thing
becomes intersectionality where you're
not just blogging to one group,
but you're also abuse characteristics.
Spin that outbursts.
What,
what,
what is the logic of that?
Where does it lead us to know?
Okay,
so the first thing I would say
to everyone in the room is,
I don't think,
and this is why I decided to do
what I did right from the beginning,
you know,
is that I don't want to play
the group identity game.
I don't want to construe the world in
those terms and I'm not going to use
terminology that would require me to
formulate my thoughts in that manner.
I think it's a terrible catastrophe
to divide us all up into our tribal
entities.
Don't see anything
positive about that at all.
So I just don't want to go there.
And then second,
I would say,
and maybe this is even more relevant,
you may or may not have heard
about intersectionality,
but intersectionality is a new
development on the radical left.
And I think it's actually,
if I wasn't so in tandem on
serious this and these matters,
I would be constantly laughing
about intersectionality.
And the reason for that is that it's
the radical left has discovered its own
Achilles heel.
So look,
what's the problem with
dividing us up into groups?
Well,
there's many.
And the descent into tribalism
is not least among them,
but the next is that,
well,
it turns out that we
don't fit into one group.
Any of us,
we fit into multiple groups.
And it's not obvious at all.
Which of those groups should take,
should be of paramount importance.
You know,
there's a racial group and
an ethnic ethnic group,
and there's groups of intelligence
and there's groups of temperament,
there's groups of attractiveness,
and there's groups of wealth and you
can multiply them really indefinitely.
And I do mean indefinitely because
you can categorize a finite number of
entities,
a virtually infinite number of ways.
And so the intersection
lists discovered this.
They said,
well,
there's,
let's say there's Latinos and there's,
and there's Asians.
It's like,
okay,
well wait a minute.
There's male and female Latinos
and there's male and female Asians.
So,
so do we treat,
is the division into two enough or
do we need a division into four?
Well then,
then,
well then there's socioeconomic
class of male and female,
Asians and male and female Latinos.
And,
and you can keep fractionating the
groups and technically without,
and,
and you actually see this
happening in real time,
so to speak,
as the,
uh,
acronym for the LGBT activists continues
to expand really without end and see
what's at the bottom of intersectionality.
And this,
I suspect,
will be discovered eventually by the
radical leftists if they get that far as
the,
you have to fractionate the groups
right down to the individual.
And that's what Western culture
discussed in articulated,
discovered in,
articulated over the last 5,000 years.
It's like,
oh,
right.
The group isn't the paramount division.
It's the individual.
Because unless you treat each
person like an individual,
you're not taking all the
intersections into account.
And so it's extraordinarily,
it's extraordinarily comedic.
But it also isn't as if it's treating
everyone as they're an individual,
as if they're an individual,
is an instant solution that
will bring us to utopia.
You know,
it's,
it's like Winston Churchill
said of democracy,
right?
It's,
it's essentially the least
terrible approach we have.
An life isn't the sort of problem that
is amenable to an instantaneous utopian
solution,
but our best bet is to meet each
other with the desire for peace and
productivity on this,
on the stage that enables individual
interaction because then we meet soul,
the soul,
so to speak.
And we also meet in a domain that we
bear responsibility for as individuals.
And that's also extremely important,
right?
You should be responsible
for what you say.
You should have to suffer the
consequences of what you say,
not least so that you learn.
And so the individual is
paramount as far as I'm concerned.
I think that's the fundamental
principle of Western civilization.
You know,
it's not only the west that
has come across that discovery,
but I think we've done the best
job so far of articulating it.
And so we don't want to lose that because
the alternative isn't a multicultural
utopia.
The alternative is a descent
into tribal barbarism.
And,
and there are people who would be
just as happy if that happened.
But I would suggest that it's not a
destiny that in a weak person would,
would,
would long for.
Yeah.
Do you feel like taking a few questions,
do you feel like taking some
questions from the storage shirt?
All right,
so we're going to have questions and
we'd like you to participate in this
conversation now.
Please do ask a question.
We welcome you up to say what you'd like.
If there is a preamble to the question
that's fairly shorts then so be it.
But please do ask a question.
We're not actually in buddy speeches
and we do primarily want to hear,
but Jordan has to say,
so feel free to line up
at the two microphones.
We'll take one at a time.
Go ahead sir.
Uh,
so first of all,
thank you so much for being here.
I really enjoyed it.
Um,
[inaudible]
and a second,
I'm,
this ties into my question.
I just last week my free speech coalition
at Bishop's University was officially
ratified and I would love to invite
you to be our first guest speaker,
if that's at all possible.
Um,
oh,
thank you.
Um,
and my,
my question pertains to this,
um,
for Dr. Peterson,
what would you consider the
most under discussed or,
um,
overlooked ideas and topics that you
think should be discussed in the club?
Because I know we're looking
for controversial ideas
that we think are maybe not
as discussed as much as they should be.
Well,
that's,
uh,
that's a difficult question.
I would say that
it isn't obvious to me that on university
campuses at the present time or in the
education system in general,
we've done a good job of taking stock of
the advantages and disadvantages of our
current sociopolitical systems now.
And I think there's enough data so
that we could start having intelligent
conversation.
So one thing I would recommend to you
all if you're interested is a book I just
finished reading.
It's called the great leveler,
the great leveler by Walter Shy Dale.
And it's a discussion of inequality
and it's a very intelligent book.
So one of,
so inequality,
as you may or may not know,
is rife throughout human societies,
right?
And that's the case in the present day.
And it's been the case historically,
but it's also the case in animal
societies by every measure.
So inequality is the rule of life,
let's say.
And that doesn't mean it's
not an ethical catastrophe.
I'm not saying that,
I'm just saying that the
fact of inequality cannot
be laid at the feet of the
west or of capitalism or,
or really have any human
construction for that matter.
One of the things Shydel did was to
investigate empirically the relationship
between inequality and
the pole of government.
So because let's say if you,
if you surveyed a very
large number of states,
you could determine whether this,
the governments were left wing
or right wing and then you could,
you could do a compilation of inequality
coefficients and you could find out if
left wing governments had any,
any ability to ameliorate inequality.
Just as an empirical question.
And the answer that
Shydel generated was no,
there's no difference whatsoever in the
inequality coefficients and left and
right wing states.
And what that points to is a
much more fundamental problem.
And Shydel in his book also points out
that the only known historical forces
that limit inequality or that produce
inequality are war revolution and
pestilence.
It's doesn't look like it's easily under,
under human control.
And so,
you know,
the Marxists talked about inequality
and the fact that capital tends to
accumulate in the hands
of fewer and fewer people,
which is sort of true,
except that the people at the top tend
to rotate lot more quickly than that.
Then the communists in the
Marxist separate presumed,
but it doesn't look like that's
a consequence of capitalism.
It looks like it's a much deeper
process and capitalism at least,
well,
it's shoveling money and resources up to
the top also does lift the bottom very,
very quickly.
You know,
and this is something we need to have
a serious discussion about it in the
university.
So like one,
because we shouldn't be doing this,
we should be partying in the streets.
And here's one reason why do you know
that the level of absolute poverty in the
world fell by 50% between the year 2000
and the year 2012 do you know that was
three years faster than the most
optimistic UN projection considered.
It was the fastest decline in absolute
poverty that the world has ever seen.
And like that's a big deal.
You know about,
there's hundreds of thousands of
people a week right now that are being
connected to the power grid and almost
everybody has access to high speed
computation.
And the,
the,
the struggling economies in Africa
have for the last four years being the
fastest growing economies in the world.
You know,
there's almost no absolute privation left.
There aren't people starving
except for political reasons.
We're at a point where
obesity is the worst,
worst problem than starvation,
you know,
and,
and now I also think that a
lot of that was purchased out,
the cost of the,
of the dreams and hopes of
the working class in the west.
You know,
I think what we did some sense for
about a 30 year period is sacrificed the
aspirations of the Western working
class to alleviate poverty,
get India and China
and in South East Asia.
And it looks like that might
have been a really good deal,
although it was a little bit hard on the
working class people and that has to be
taken into account,
but we're not having discussions
of is sort universities.
It's like we're stuck in 1980 or maybe
a 1960 we haven't updated our bottles.
We take into account the new and often
extraordinarily positive realities and
we're tearing ourselves apart
in the west with this identity,
politics,
idiocy.
At the same time,
the things are getting better and better,
faster and faster than they ever have
by a huge margin in the history of
mankind.
So it's like,
it's time to wake up and throw off
the depression of the Cold War and,
and,
and to look around and see what's what's
available in front of us and what we
could accomplish that would
be much better than Oh,
yes.
Yeah.
So
right.
Told that,
uh,
there are developments outside.
I'm sorry for the noise.
The,
uh,
we'll will,
they're doing the best they can.
Uh,
yes ma'am.
Was there a fetus in youth said that
Europe had one was one of your highest
priorities is the pursuit of truth?
Could you just clarify what Ruth,
you mean when you're presented
with a situation where you have to,
or you're being asked to refer to
someone to their preferred pronouns,
and is it,
is it a truth they do see is
that their truth is your truth
be the issue
isn't the request of the individual
to be addressed in a certain matter.
It's the compulsion of that by law.
So at least issues get
conflated constantly.
Look,
I've dealt with all sorts
of people in my life,
a much broader range of people than most
people ever encounter in the course of
their entire lives.
And I'm perfectly capable of deciding
how to treat someone on a one to one
basis.
But when the demand for,
for terminology becomes
part of the legal system,
I don't care what the rationale is.
It's not happening as
far as I'm concerned.
And people say,
well,
we're pushing it forward
because of compassion.
And maybe you could stop just
being such a mean professor.
It's like,
why should I believe that?
You know what the hell you're
doing with your compelling laws.
You're willing to,
you're willing to move past illegal wine
in the sand that's been drawn for let's
say,
700 years.
You do not write compelled speech into
the legislation all but we're doing it
with the best of intense.
Yeah.
No,
you're not.
So these issues have to be separate.
Look,
if this was about transgender rights,
it would have disappeared in September
of 2016 it's not about transgender rights
and everyone knows it.
So this is not about transgender rights.
What these,
what these people are doing outside.
It's about something far deeper than that.
We ask the question this way.
Can we say,
don't
have the rights,
the liberty to decide how
to present themselves.
You know how to be who they want to be,
what's aware.
You know,
what,
what gender to call themselves.
And the answer is yes.
Everybody has the liberty to do that.
What everybody else has liberty too.
And the liberty to do that doesn't mean
they have the right to compel other
people to agree with it.
In other words,
liberty is not the right to demand that
the world validate the choices that
you've made.
You have your choices,
you have the freedom to make the choices
and everybody else has the freedom to
make their choices too and to approve
or disapprove and they call you this or
like all your that.
In other words,
liberty is a two way street
and everybody has it.
And the fact that you've made choices,
it doesn't mean everybody else doesn't
have the same ability to make the same
choices
back.
Mike,
Please go ahead.
Hi.
Um,
that was loud.
I just want to thank you for being here.
I'm really big fan and um,
I have a bad habit of making or,
uh,
getting in arguments with a lot of
radical leftists and I'm the most common
argument they present to me,
I generally is bills you 16 only
covers the Ontario human rights code.
So those are protected areas under
the Ontario Human Rights Code,
uh,
such as,
universities,
uh,
elementary schools,
et cetera.
I was just wondering,
um,
how you would combat this argument.
Seeing is their argument is generally,
um,
they're only dealing with vulnerable
groups such as young students and um,
he's still got about enough.
It doesn't matter.
They say,
well it's,
it's restricted in scope.
Yeah.
It's not restricted enough.
Look,
here's a couple of facts.
Okay.
So when I first made my video
is about bill [inaudible] 16,
one of the things that I suggested was
that the act of making the video itself
could well have been illegal.
And of course people immediately accused
me of fear mongering and perhaps with
reasons,
it's not always easy to understand
the full intent of the new piece of
legislation surrounding policies.
But I can tell you one thing.
When the lawyers at the University of
Toronto read through the new legislation
and the surrounding policies,
they also decided that what I was doing
might've been transgressing the law.
And that's why they wrote me
two letters telling me to stop.
Okay.
So that's number one.
Okay,
fact
number two,
two words,
Lindsay Shepherd.
Okay,
so
let's say for the argument
that I'm a paranoid,
make a little maniac and that I'm a
bigot and all of the other things that
people have decided that I might be okay.
Well,
I'll tell you what,
in my paranoid Megalomania,
I never envisioned a situation
where a teaching assistant,
a 22 year old teaching assistant at a
major Canadian university would be hold in
front of a quasi myo is inquisition and
have to record it because she dared to
show five minutes of a video from a
mainstream news program run by public
television funded by the
government of Ontario.
So paranoid as I was,
let's say,
it isn't obvious that
I was paranoid enough.
So,
and I don't see that.
I don't see how either of
those examples can be disputed.
You know,
it wasn't like the University of Toronto
wrote me two letters without thinking
about it.
They went and consulted their high powered
lawyers and the lawyers reviewed the
policies and the legislation
and they thought,
oh,
Dr. Peterson,
he might be contravening that legislation.
It's like,
it was a weird paradoxical gift to me
that they sent out those two letters
telling me to stop because it was
instant proof that what I was doing was,
um,
I wouldn't say right because
God only knows about that.
But at least if my interpretation of
the bill and its intent was correct,
so can we just make this observation that,
that,
that response to Jordan's
critique of see 16,
the one that went,
oh,
he's overreacting.
Nobody's going to be punished
or sent to jail for this
silly.
In this sense,
remember,
every single legal rule there is,
is a legal rule only because
it is backed with the mum.
Monopolistic violence of the state.
They're ready.
[inaudible]
there's no such thing as a
rural without punishment.
So if,
if for example,
there's a no parking sign,
what the practicing science says,
oh by the way,
please don't park here.
But there are no tickets.
Well people are going to park
cause that's not really a rule.
So if you have a rule in the human
rights code and if you breach it,
if that's discrimination,
well then true.
The first thing that happens to you
is not going to be thrown in jail.
But there's a process,
a series of steps,
right?
The first one might be a mediation or an
investigation and then there might be a
fine.
And then if you don't pay the fine,
then your wages might be garnished
or you might be ordered to fix it.
But believe me,
if you refuse and refuse
and refuse and refuse,
that order will become a court order.
And then if you don't
obey the court order,
you'll be in contempt of court.
And then that will lead to
arrest and imprisonment.
So every single rule in
the human rights code
is effectively enforced with the
most severe violence the state has,
even though it's not actually
practiced most of the time.
Because most people obey
when we,
we also don't want to underestimate,
I don't know how many of you have had
the pleasure of being dragged before a
board that investigates your behavior,
but I would tell you that even if you
don't end up paying a fine or in jail,
there's nothing particularly
pleasant about the process itself.
It's enough.
You know you wonder why people don't
speak up and I can tell you one of the
reasons they don't speak up is because
merely being dragged in front of a board
of inquiry,
innocent or guilty is enough to pretty
much do you in for a whole year.
Like if you're a sensible person and
you're concerned with propriety and you
want to maintain the stability of your
life and your reputation is important to
you,
perhaps because of the stability of your
family depends on it to be investigated
for such things as a punishment.
All of its own.
It's no,
it's no pleasant business and
many of you will you're and stuff.
I would,
I would equate being investigated
by a non punitive court,
let's say with these punishments that
Bruce described quite far down the
distance.
I would equate that to having a,
a fairly serious disease in terms of its,
in terms of it's psychological
and physical impact.
I would also say
no I won't,
I won't say it.
Let's go with the next project
that's across the place.
Thank you.
First of all,
they can vote
as embarrassing as what's happening
out there is easy university.
I think what it does when I could
show how what we're doing here,
is it how we can,
those people are so thank you.
First of all,
[inaudible] of my questions,
your belief that it's extremely important.
Everything that we're doing to
speak our mind speaking freely.
That's why we're here.
But in terms of practicality,
there's a lot of things that get,
are in the way of her license.
Students,
you know,
we have our prospective soap.
Um,
in terms of practicality,
what are kind of maybe your tips and your
perspective on the steps that students
can take to kind of speak their mind
while not sacrificing their future back?
Well,
I can tell you a couple of
things that are very practical.
Don't break in your essence what you
think the professor wants to hear.
There's absolutely no excuse
whatsoever for doing that.
Now,
first of all,
most professors,
even those who have descended into
a state of ideological possession,
let's say most
of them still have enough character
to breed an essay that's well written.
So you're actually taking less of a risk
than you would think by stating what
you have to stay.
But look,
if you start practicing when you
were in University of mistakes,
you're rather low
pandering to the audience,
let's say and say what you
think will get you buy.
You're going to train yourself to do that.
And what that means is you're going to
train yourself in the false suffocation
of your character and your character
is the only thing you have to guide you
through life.
No people dream of riches.
And they dream of luxury and all of that.
But that's a thin defense against
the harsh realities of the world.
You have your character.
And so what you do when
you go to university is you
learn to say what you think
is clearly as you can and to take the
slings and arrows that come along with
that.
No,
I didn't.
An hitting manner,
right?
Because like what the hell do you know?
You know,
so you've got plenty to learn,
but you want to formulate
your thoughts carefully.
You want to write what you think.
Well,
why?
Because when you're writing,
you're thinking,
you're laying out the arguments that
you're going to use to structure your
existence in the world
throughout your entire life.
And if you start to twist and
bend those for expedient reasons,
you're going to warp your soul.
And I mean,
I could talk about that
neurophysiologically if you want to,
you know,
you become what you practice,
you automate what you practice.
So if you automate expedient speech
for the sake of short term gain,
then that's what you're going to produce.
You're going to produce expedient
speech for short term gain.
Well God help you if you do that,
like there is nothing that you will
possibly do in your entire life that will
serve you better than to get
control of your voice in university.
I remember seeing you do that by reading,
right?
You read great people.
You do that by writing what you think.
You stay true to yourself while you write
what you think and you take the risks
and you gain the benefits
that go along with that.
You learn to stand up and speak and to
listen carefully and that makes you a
negotiator of unparalleled power.
And if you're a negotiator
of unparalleled power,
there's nothing in the world
that won't open itself up to you.
So that's what you're doing in university.
And if you find professors who,
who reject that and there's fewer
of them than you might think,
then it's your sacred obligation to stand
up for yourself against that because
it's going to happen to you
throughout your whole life.
And you might as well start
practicing how to do it right now.
So that's how it looks to me.
Yeah.
There's an old saying that I write
[inaudible]
I write in order to know what I think.
And you'll note how compelled
speech interferes in that process.
Yes.
So the idea that you have to write what
professor wants is a form of compelled
speech.
It's like it.
I really do believe that
this is a fundamental issue.
As a therapist,
say when I'm trying to help
someone set their life straight,
I do my best not to compel their speech.
And the reason for that is quite clear.
It's like you have your destiny with
all its attended triumphs and sufferings
and it's on your shoulders.
I don't want to tell you how to think.
I don't want to tell you how to think
because I do not know how you should
think.
You have to figure that
out for yourself and,
and then you have to bear
the responsibility for that.
And you,
you were a terribly arrogant fool.
If you dare to tell someone else how it
is that they should conduct themselves
through life.
Now.
I mean,
having said that,
while obviously I say,
well,
you should tell the truth or
at least you shouldn't lie,
but that's not a dictate of,
of,
of actions so to speak.
It's a dictate of process.
It's like,
well,
you can't,
you shouldn't interfere with the
mechanism that allows you to solve all the
problems that you will face in your
life and you come to university maybe to
prepare for,
uh,
for a,
for a profession,
no,
and to set yourself up economically,
but to set yourself economic economically,
properly.
I don't care what your
profession is going to be.
There is no one who is more powerful
than someone who can communicate.
It doesn't matter what the field,
it doesn't matter if you're
a plumber or a politician.
If you can formulate
your thoughts clearly.
If you can conduct yourself honorably
in your action and your speech,
if you're articulate and careful,
then the world opens itself up to you.
You have an unlimited
horizon of possibility.
So thank you very much.
Yup.
[inaudible]
oh,
thank you both for coming with,
firstly,
I'd like to thank everyone in the room
who is not devolved into the hysteria we
see outside.
They would prefer that we lost our sanity
and that our society would fracture
into the nonsense we see.
So by sitting here,
being as patient as you are,
this is how we keep our academy.
This is how we keep our society.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
my question is a simple one.
Uh,
we see more and more of this
new language I call of leftism,
intersectionality,
equity,
diversity,
inclusion,
and we see people from all political and
philosophical straights adopting this
new vernacular.
Is this in any way dignifying
that as a position,
is this dignifying the
philosophical bases of these words?
Do people recognize that
when they use these,
uh,
these words that they making that
somehow a truth that we all ought to,
except I don't,
should we or should we not?
I don't think people,
you recognize that.
Again,
you know what I'd like reiterate with
the reason I made those videos to begin
with was because I don't,
I was unwilling to see the linguistic
territory as soon as you think it's
already happening to some degree.
So imagine that we just did define the
sociopolitical landscape in terms of
identity politics,
which is happening very rapidly.
In fact,
we're compelled to do so.
Right?
So,
um,
well then,
then what happens is you get activity on
the identity politics front on the left
and on the right the left says,
well,
the oppressed shall rise and
take their rightful place.
And the right says,
yeah,
over my dead body and probably yours too.
So as soon as we played
the identity politics game,
that's where we're at.
And we start playing it by
accepting the terminology.
You know,
already I find myself stumbling when
I used the word sex instead of gender.
And that's not good.
Like I have to consciously overcome a
resistance to use the word sex instead of
gender because you know,
I'm actually quite an agreeable
person and it actually pains me to,
to go against the crowd.
Let's say,
you know,
I'm not temperamentally
suited for it precisely,
strangely enough.
And so I feel the compulsion to use this
kind of language welling up inside of
me just to be,
to be nice,
I suppose,
you know,
but I know where identity politics leads.
It leads to the Ghoulag,
it leads to the concentration camps.
It leads to blood in the streets.
We don't need that here.
We're doing pretty well.
So we could leave it.
Hi,
Professor Peterson.
Uh,
I studied history for the duration
of my degree and I think it's just a
sickeningly ironic that the people
who are using their free speech,
one to take away your free speech and
furthermore that they can't see the irony
of this situation of how
tyrannical there being a,
my question is,
however,
um,
I've noticed from a lot of what you've
talked about and I've been watching you
since your rise in 2060,
2016,
um,
and I know that you're a Christian
and I don't want to divulge into that,
but I noticed a lot of the sort of
North American Protestant work ethic in,
in,
uh,
in your lessons.
Like,
you know,
uh,
self redemption and to be your own person.
Like we've been talking about that
last like hour and a half I suppose.
And um,
in a ever rising tide where people are,
or rather in the western world where
it's becoming increasingly rather
decreasingly Christian and specifically,
yeah.
Decreasingly religious nuns
specifically decreasingly Christian.
How can you,
what do you think is the best suggestion
in order to be able to uphold those
such important values that
have been across the world,
uh,
from American cultural influence
since the end of the Second World War?
I apologize for the long question.
No,
no,
it's fine.
You know,
people have asked me
repeatedly my religious views
and I've answered them in a
variety of different ways,
but they say,
do you believe in God?
Let's say my response to that always is,
well,
I don't know what you mean
when you ask me that question.
So I don't know how to answer it.
I don't know what you mean by belief,
but I can tell you something that I
believe and I would say this is a way of
speaking symbolically.
I do believe so.
I was thinking the other day and week
ago I was thinking about this I this
little fantasy that entered my mind.
I was thinking about Saint Joseph's
oratorial in Montreal and Saint Joseph's
oratory.
It was a very large religious building.
It's one of the biggest cathedral
light structures in the world,
and it's set on the hill and mount royal
and it's set up where it can catch the
sun,
you know?
So it's an image of the
heavenly city on the hill,
right?
It's an image of the structures
that we strive to create.
That's what it is in independent of
its specifically Christian or religious
function.
That's what it stands for symbolically.
Okay,
so it's the city on the hill.
It's,
it's what we're striving towards
when we walk up hill in life.
Okay?
Now the way the,
the,
the oratory,
it was structured,
there's hundreds of steps
leading to it up front.
And in the early part of the 20th century,
a lot of people who had
physical disabilities came
there and they struggled up
the step on their crutches and many
of them left their crutches in the
oratorial.
You can see hundreds of
them if you go there.
It's quite an interesting site.
And I was thinking about that and I was
thinking about what that meant and this
is what it means.
It means that you know,
everyone has their disabilities,
let's say,
and I know that some people are far more
terribly effected than other people.
I'm perfectly aware of that.
But the question is what
do you do about that?
And what you do is you set yourself up
on your damn crutches and you struggle up
the bloody hill.
That's what you do.
And you struggle up the hill
towards the Kingdom of God.
That's what you do because the
alternative is to descend into the abyss.
That's the alternative.
And then so to say,
well,
do you believe it's like I believe that
you should struggle uphill towards the
city of God on your crutches.
That's what you should do.
That's the opposite of the
descent into the abyss.
And so that's,
that's at the foundation
of our civilization.
That idea.
Well,
argue with it.
If you will,
see if you can figure out why
that's not an acceptable idea.
Maybe you should help
someone's struggle up the hill.
Perhaps you should,
you know,
you can lend a hand to someone or you
don't want to take the burden away from
them entirely because there's something
noble about struggling up the Damn Hill,
right?
There's something that's adventure.
That's the call to proper being.
It's like,
well,
we don't need to forget this.
No,
we don't need to forget it.
The universities have been there since
time in memorial to try to push that idea
forward through the generations,
and everyone needs to know that idea.
That's what gives you life,
not happiness.
Forget about that.
If it comes,
well,
great.
Except it dignity,
nobility,
character,
truth,
responsibility,
beauty.
Those are the things to aim for honor too.
I'd say honor.
Thank you very much and I
hope when all this is done,
I hope you take a nice long,
big vacation cause I think
you really deserve it.
Hello.
Okay,
Peterson first.
Thank you for coming.
And I'm so,
I'm Chinese.
My parents grew up in the
cultural revolution of China,
so I took particular attention when
you mentioned the multiple occasions
comparing what's happening
in the West right now,
two miles,
China and I,
I agree and it's pretty obvious the
connection between their radiology,
the identity politics and the
oppression versus oppressed viewpoints.
But my question is mostly about how
they're promoting the political agenda.
I mean,
I see that the political agenda,
the philosophy behind the
political agenda are very similar,
but at the same time,
I see a shocking similarity in the
way that they promoting that political
agenda.
Specifically backing back
in the culture revolution.
Anyone who dare to say anything that
it's not fully for the movement was
classified as Nq revolutionary.
Just as now who anyone who dare to
say anything that goes remotely,
not fully aligned with whatever they
want to promote is classified as hate
speech.
Although it has nothing to
do with hate hating anybody.
So since the same thing is
happening here and a Mao's China,
what would you say?
Well,
what,
what do you think is the connection
between the philosophy and they're idiotic
oversimplifying and tyrannical way of him,
of trying to promoting it?
Well,
the first thing,
the first thing we should make clear
is that there is such a thing as hate
speech,
right?
Like let's not be naive about this and
you can use words to inflame and words
can be very dangerous tools.
People use them and hateful
matters all the time.
That's not the issue.
That's obvious.
The issue is whether or not you should
regulate out and even more importantly,
whether the state should regulate it.
And the reason that's an issue is
because who's going to define it?
I'll tell you who's going
to define hate speech.
It's the people who are doing that
that are going to define hate speech.
And right now they're defining you
sitting in here as hate speech.
I mean,
that's exactly what's
going on while we sit here.
It's like who would be interested in
defining the parameters of hate speech?
Here's the answer.
The people that you would least want to
have adopt that responsibility and and
hate speech.
It's like,
let's say I was interviewed a while
back and the journalist asked me,
well,
why should your right to a family Trump,
someone's right to be secure?
It's like,
okay,
well let's say I'm talking to
one person and you might say,
well I don't have the
right to offend them.
It's like,
all right,
what if I'm talking to 10 people?
Do I have the right to offend one of
those people when I speak to the mortar,
if it's a thousand people,
what you're saying
[inaudible]
you can't,
you can't have a conversation about
something serious without offense.
Like if I'm thinking
about something serious,
like I often myself,
you know,
and I seriously mean that.
I really mean that.
So like if I'm laying
out a set of hypotheses,
for example,
about a complex social,
a social problem,
I might lay out 20 hypothesis
and maybe two of them.
I thank God,
I hope that's not true.
But like maybe it is true.
You know,
sometimes you discover things as a social
scientist that you wish were true and
those are usually the things that you've
discovered that are actually true,
right?
Cause they violate your assumptions.
So you can't even think if you're
not willing to offend yourself.
That's what thinking does.
If you're ever talking about something
wouldn't be serious if it didn't have the
possibility of frightening
and offending people.
That's kind of how the,
that's kind of like the
definition of seriousness.
It's like,
well,
we can only talk about things
that no one ever gets upset about.
It's like,
well
then it's like you're
trapped in an elevator for,
for the rest of infinity listening
to nothing but Muzak you're,
that's an,
that's a kind of hell man.
If you're going to think,
and also if you're going to speak,
you're going to,
you're going to offend people.
You're going to go after their deepest
presuppositions and end your own as well.
You're going to shatter them at times.
It's going to be brutal.
Absolutely brutal.
And you all know that because every
single one of you has had a serious
conversation with someone that you love
and the probability that that was an
easy conversation and that either of you
escaped without offense and terror is
zero.
If you haven't had a
conversation like that,
well,
well
you're not human,
right?
I mean right.
Cause everyone has conversations like
that all the time except when they run
from them,
which is most of the time
and no bloody wonder,
you know,
real conversations or there's nothing
worse than a real conversation except the
war that you have if you
don't have the conversation.
That's basically how it goes.
I just want to underline,
I just want to underline
Jordan's first point,
which is really that it's
a very dangerous thing.
Any legal rule that relies on some kind
of reasonableness because reasonableness
lies in the eyes of the beholder.
I mean,
those out there
think that you guys are
uttering hate speech.
They think that you guys should be the
one who are arrested and just imagine if
they were the ones who had
the reins of government power.
Just all very well hate
speech as a reasonable idea.
But as soon as you give up the
control about what that means,
you're liable to run into real trouble.
Yup.
Hello,
Mr. Rowe.
Well,
Mr. Peterson,
my name is Zachary Milligan.
Uh,
first off,
I'd just like to start to actually thank
you for all the hardship and troubles
even dirt for standing up for our
rights and being a part of this debate.
Um,
I come from a dairy farm and math
need rural res conservatively.
And my question is in the face of
when we have a social situation,
so divisive,
when you genuinely believe what
you're doing is the right thing.
In this particular instance,
since you have experience with it,
what would you say?
Is there a more effective,
I don't want to say an easy
way to reach out for them,
but what do you think's the best way to
try and talk some sense into those folks
outside and the one on one setting?
So the first thing is is I
don't necessarily the day
I don't necessarily think
that what I'm doing is the
right thing because you know,
you have to be careful when
you make a claim like that.
But I can tell you one thing,
I'm not going to let anyone stand in the
way of me trying to figure out what the
right thing is.
That's the thing.
And then I would say we're doing exactly
what we should be doing right now in
this discussion.
It's,
it's just exactly right,
right?
I mean,
admittedly we have to talk over the noise,
but that's really not that big a
catastrophe and everybody's in here is
comporting themselves
in a reasonable manner.
And we're trying to struggle our
way through the topics and we're,
we're asking questions and we're,
we're trying to have a
genuine dialogue about them.
And that's what we've got.
We've got,
we've got three things.
We've got negotiation,
we've got slavery,
and we've got tyranny.
And those are your choices.
And so this is negotiation,
right?
That's public discourse.
And the reason that freedom of speech
thought is obviously important.
And everyone can understand that.
You might say,
well,
you don't need to speak freely because
you can think who's going to get inside
your head.
But the problem with that
is that that's not it.
You can't think very well because
there you are and your little world,
you know,
with all your biases and your ignorance,
you're wrong about so many things and
you're going to learn it really painfully.
And,
and then maybe you can trot out some
of the things you think erroneously and
ignorantly and other people will give
you a tap on the side of the head instead
of running you over with a freight train,
right?
They'll give you a little tap on the side
of the head and maybe you'll walk away
a little smarter.
And that's why freedom of
speech is so important,
just because a lot of thinking,
especially about things that are
beyond you for whatever reason,
have to take place publicly as we stumble
around towards an adequate formulation
of the problems that beset us.
So I would say,
well in this book I wrote,
I have a rule.
It's,
I think it's rule eight which is
tell the truth or at least don't lie.
I would say,
well,
that's another reasonable,
a reasonable way to start approaching
the situation is it's not so easy to tell
the truth because like,
what do you know?
You know,
you can't come out and say,
well,
here's the truth,
but I know what one thing you can do,
which is when you know that what you're
saying is a lie by your own standards,
you can not say it and you can have a
consultation with yourself and you can try
to learn to say those
things that make you strong.
Instead of saying those things
that make you weak and you,
you contribute to the health of the
public dialogue in an incalculable manner
that way.
And this is another issue that pertains
to the dignity and importance of the
individual.
How you conduct yourself in your life
is way more important than you think.
And,
and I mean I think that that's a
daunting idea because you know,
let's say you're nihilistic
and life is meaningless.
It's,
well,
what's the payoff for that?
I think,
well,
there's no payoff.
It's like,
well,
yeah,
there is,
you have no responsibility.
That's a pretty decent pay off.
I mean,
you have to pay the
price of meaninglessness,
but it doesn't matter what you do.
Well,
we'll flip that over and said,
no,
sorry,
you're wrong.
Your life is meaningful.
It's way more meaningful than you think,
but you have to bear responsibility
for your thoughts and your actions.
It's like you'll,
there'll be plenty of meaning and not
well that if you understand that property,
that will,
that will cleave you to the depths of
your soul and maybe you learn to speak
carefully at the act carefully and
that will have a beneficial effect on
everyone around you if far more.
You're far more powerful in the place
you stand in the place you sit and stand
than you think.
And I think everyone has
an intimation of that.
And if you don't think that's true,
then try treating people
around you as if it's not true.
Tried treating people that you know in
your life as if they don't matter and
just see what kind of response you get.
People are not going to be happy with you,
not in any sense whatsoever.
You'll,
you'll ruin all your relationships.
You have to treat people
as if they matter.
And maybe you have to treat them as
if they matter because maybe they do.
And that goes for you too.
And so if you matter,
then you should act like you matter.
And that's a very,
that's a very daunting proposition.
That's for sure.
As a foot.
Go ahead.
As a,
it's just a footnote to that.
Let's just observe this in legal terms.
There are only two categories of actions,
voluntary and involuntary.
Don't let anybody tell you otherwise,
either you're choosing on your own and,
and handling the consequences or the
government is telling you what to do.
Those are the only two possibilities.
Thank you,
sir.
At the back.
Go ahead.
Oh Duh.
Hello,
Dr. Peterson.
I would like to recall the part in your
conversation in which you mentioned how
the radical left switched from the 1960s
and seventies to being pro back when
they were a pro free
speech and their recent,
um,
opposition to it.
I know,
I know that you often mentioned
their obsession with power,
at least among them.
Yes.
At least among their more Marxists types.
I was one,
no,
I'm doing,
if perhaps they think that now,
now is the opportunity where they can
consolidate their power and if they do so
successfully that it will become the
mortality of our civilization for the next
thousand years.
Like Christianity was when Rome adopted.
Is that from what you've seen,
would you say that that's about it,
that that's close to the way there
that's close to their strategy?
Well,
it's hard to exactly understand
the strategy of an ideology,
you know,
because well all the people
who were outside were,
were United in some sense under the
umbrella of an idea and on an idea is a
living thing.
I mean it's embedded in living tissue
and it's distributed in the fragmentary
manner across the mob,
let's say.
And each person in the mob always
only only possess is a fragment of the
ideology because the full neo Marxist,
let's say the full neo Marxist
postmodernist doctrine is quite complex.
And,
and,
but when you get the mob together,
then it acts under the
dictate of the ideology.
And the question then is,
well,
what does the ideology want?
And I would say,
well,
it wants what it's
formulators says it wants.
And D Derrida for example,
who's head trickster of the postmodernists
regarded the western society as
fellow go centric.
Right?
And North that meant was male dominant,
male dominated.
That's the fellow fellas part.
And then logo centric.
While that refers to the word logos,
which means it's the root word of logic,
but there's also the,
it's also the,
the person of Christ,
essentially the logos.
And so the purpose of the postmodern
critique was to demolish that wealth.
Fair enough.
My sense with people is,
especially if they're,
if they've written things down and
thought them through that they're actually
aiming for what they say
they're aiming for.
Well,
if you,
if you buy the idea that the
west is a male dominated tyranny,
essentially a patriarchal tyranny,
and that your moral
duty is to tear it down,
well then that's what you're doing.
And then you might say,
well,
what's going to,
what is going to be erected on its ashes?
Well,
that's where things get complicated.
You know,
the first question might be,
are the people who wish to tear it down?
Builders,
or are they just destroyers?
And my strong sentiment is that
they're primarily destroyers.
Now you might say,
well,
why do people wish to destroy?
Well,
it's because they're hurt by
life and they're resentful
and resentful.
People become vengeful and vengeful.
People become dangerous.
And there's no shortage of
motivation to make things worse.
Now that the school
shooters make things worse,
people make things worse.
Now,
you know,
maybe lurking in the rhetoric is this
appealed to an egalitarian utopia,
but we've tried utilitarian
utopia is already,
we sacrificed 100 million people
to [inaudible] Galitary in utopias,
and we have yet to produce one.
And so my sense is the corpse is stacked
up high enough to constitute proof.
So
it's destruction mostly that
motivates it as far as I can tell,
masquerading as compassion.
[inaudible]
thank you for that question.
Next place.
Dr. Peterson.
I said party.
Thank you both for being here today.
Um,
I'm a political scientist and what
I've studied is totalitarian regimes.
I'm sorry,
I'm gonna move this a little bit.
To feel weird.
Totalitarian regimes.
I've studied,
I've tried to look at the Iranian
revolution and the Islamic Republican,
Iran,
and I've argued how the Shia Islam that
is teached in Islamic public is very
close to a totalitarian regime.
But now I live in a country where my
ideas are considered controversial.
If you believe in God,
if you believe in family,
if you believe in having
responsibility and traditional values,
I feel ostracized by the community here.
I came from UFC,
university of Calgary over there,
I didn't feel this way.
There was more welcoming.
Here I feel marginalized
and I do feel alone.
And when I see this,
it disgusts me that here they can do this.
But I couldn't go to their
events and do anything.
I'd have to shut up,
there'd be disciplinary committee for me.
But for them they can break windows
to God knows how old this building is.
And it's okay for them to do that.
So my question to you is now being sheer,
experiencing this,
I'm starting to second guess that maybe
the totalitarian Islamic regime that I
was so,
you know,
talking about and critical
of back in Iran isn't so bad.
When I have a choice between having to
be here and be depressed and be there and
at least have my ideas
be okay with Lou regime.
So my argument is if this free speech
and the arguments you're guys are making
here,
it doesn't work.
Would that not be the next step for
people to go towards totalitarianism?
If dialogue fails and isn't force
of arms the only thing left?
How can people compromise
when they don't want to talk,
when they want to yell?
Thank you.
Okay.
I think you make it very good point.
I don't think we should fool ourselves.
This is about force and it is a,
it's almost a dare to suggest that that
certain elements are not allowed to
enforce their view of the world
and that speaking contrary to it,
isn't that a front to those values
and they won't shut you down.
I mean that,
that that is what is at stake.
We,
we,
we are,
we are.
We are no longer really in a situation
where this will all be resolved through
sort of gentle,
reasonable civil dialogue
that happens on the side,
but it's not real anymore.
It's not really where
the fight is happening.
This is a,
an imposition of the force of
the state and it is skewed.
It's skewed a certain way
and we're getting to the
point where a certain kind of
language,
a curtain,
certain kind of dialogue is,
is approved and all
right and a certain kind.
It is not.
And that is the campaign that is
going on that this is all part of.
And I have to say that,
that your presence here and,
and your endorsement of this kind of
event is the kind of thing that has the
major pushback to that trend.
But the trend is continuing
and is a very dangerous one.
And uh,
this is,
uh,
a difficult moment in
the life of this country.
Would you,
would you say
Jordan Peele?
So,
so some,
some comments about,
about your career,
let's say.
Okay,
so you're a young mountain and you've
got lots of years ahead of you.
So you know,
you want to prepare for the
war and not for the battle,
right?
Okay.
Cause there's going to be many
battles for you personally and perhaps
politically and all of that.
And so you want to make yourself as
articulate and educated as you can and you
want to have patients.
I wouldn't say that there
is no cause for despair,
you know?
I believe that the people
who are attempting to
radicalize our society and to
transform it into a battleground of
identity politics are in a distinct
minority,
and I think that,
I think that there's no reason to assume
that we can't push the devil back into
the,
into the bottle,
so to speak,
to push the genie back into the bottle,
and so don't despair.
Now from a personal perspective,
it's like we've got lots of things to
learn and you've got lots of things to say
and to write and you're going to find now
and then that you were imposed upon in
a manner that you don't find tolerable.
Right?
You think,
I can't live like this,
right?
It's going to distress you and well then,
then you've come across
your moral conundrum,
right?
It's specific to you and then you have to,
that's when you have to grow
up and think strategically.
It's like you decide are you willing
to live under those conditions?
If you're not,
then you develop a strategy.
It's like,
okay,
I'm going to,
I'm going to fight this.
I'm going to fight it carefully,
intelligently,
thoughtfully on multiple fronts
and I'm not going to back down.
You don't make that decision lightly.
You know most things you should let blow
by you because there's not that much of
you and there's lots of things,
but now and then you'll find a stumbling
block that you can't get over it
because it hurts you.
It damages your soul.
That's the right way to think about it.
Well then that's the time for
you to put your education to use.
You know,
and you'll be able to do that.
I mean,
you don't want to underestimate
the utility of of deep,
forthright speech.
I don't believe that anything
can stand in its way.
You have the courage of your convictions,
but don't give way to despair.
Like this battle is by no means over.
Nope.
I know meat and it isn't even obvious
that the bad guys are winning,
so to speak.
You know?
I mean,
here we are,
we're having this talk.
The university came out forthrightly
in favor of free speech.
Hooray for that
[inaudible]
no one and so far all the questions today
have been thoughtful and intelligent.
You seem like informed people.
It's like don't
underestimate your strength.
And so,
and McMaster just published a set of
guidelines governing this sort of behavior
so that will no longer be acceptable to
disrupt perfectly reasonable proceedings
on university campuses.
And so that,
so the discussions like
this can continue properly.
I mean there's definitely a place for
give and take and for informed opposition,
let's say.
But there's a difference between informed
opposition and child childish grand
standing.
And I think people know the
difference between that.
So don't,
don't be desperate about it
by not pick your battles.
A little courage goes a long way,
right?
Because other people
see it and there's that,
there is,
I think a silent majority out
there that is silent and is scared.
But if they see courage from somebody,
they responded to it.
Well,
I think you described lawyers in
a way that appealed to me once.
He said,
I think,
I know that's rare,
but
you said lawyers,
I think these are the words you said.
Lawyers are
difficult and emotionally stable.
And it was the combination
of those two things,
the willingness to be difficult,
but not to be emotional about it.
So don't,
don't,
where'd your emotions to the fight?
Take a step back,
engage in it,
see what you think.
Be Courageous,
but don't get wrapped up in it.
Don't be emotional about it,
but you know,
retain your strength for the long haul.
Yup.
Well,
you know,
one of the things I've
learned strategically,
and this is really we're
thinking about too,
is that when you're engaged
in a public dispute like this,
it's not obvious when
things are going your way.
You know,
you think,
well,
this protest is not such a good thing.
It's like,
I wouldn't be so sure about that.
You know what's happened to me in the
last 18 months is that virtually every
time that I been attacked and some
of the attacks have been quite well,
I wouldn't say brutal because we
haven't got to that thank God,
but they've certainly been,
um,
they've taken me aback.
You know,
it's not,
it's not a straight forward
thing to be in a hall with.
And this happened at McMaster with a
hundred people yelling at you and Larry
near horns and all of that.
But that wasn't a bad thing as it turned
out because it was filmed and it was
put on Youtube and it was terrible
for the people who protested,
you know,
it wasn't good.
And so you got to detach yourself to,
you know,
if,
if you say what you think
and you're careful about it,
it's going to have some short term
effects and it's going to have some medium
term with exit.
It's going to have some long term effects.
And one of the things that you need to do,
I would say,
and this is an element of courage,
is you have to have faith that the medium
to longterm consequences of you saying
what you have to say
as clearly as possible.
It's going to be positive and you
have to act on that supposition.
You don't know,
right?
You can't know that that's the
existential leap of faith is you.
You can't know,
but you act anyway.
And my experience has been
that you don't want to,
you don't want to make judgment too
quickly because it's not always clear when
things are going your way.
So when you know,
you might stand up into class and say
something that people react negatively to
eat and you might get pilloried
for that by some people,
but you never know who you're touching
in the crowd and you don't know how
that's going to unfold across time.
Now you who that might be a defining
moment in someone else's life to watch you
stand up and say what you have to say.
So don't underestimate the power
of truth and courage really.
So
[inaudible]
honestly,
they should be thankful.
And how civil and how
peaceful you guys are.
They should be thankful.
They shouldn't be angry.
I regret to say we probably
have time for probably
just a couple more questions.
So let's
go to the back.
Hi.
Um,
so my question is
directed at Dr. Peterson.
Um,
I've been watching your lectures
online for a while and um,
you talk a lot,
come a little closer to the bank,
you speak a lot about that's better.
You speak a lot about character arc types
and a narrative and the importance of
the young Ian idea of the
personal narrative.
Um,
I
am having trouble formulating
this into a question,
but I guess with the idea
of art types in mind,
um,
are you familiar with,
uh,
been neue Mandel broads
idea of fractal patterns?
Um,
and if so,
what do you think and if,
is there a connection
there maybe to be found?
Well,
there seems to be a metaphorical
connection in that the great is,
is reproduced in the small,
and that's certainly
an idea that permeates,
let's say religious and
theological speculation.
You know,
there's an idea that here's an idea
that it's like the idea of the genie,
which is the re same root word as genius,
the genius,
something of unimaginable power that's
constrained in a very small space.
And that's kind of what a person is like.
You know,
we have this affinity,
we have this connection to the infinite,
we have this connection to the divine,
but we're,
but it's constrained
within within our frames,
right?
And we have to act out that the divine
narrative in the confines of our own
life.
And so there is this overarching reality,
which is something like the fo
the forthright confrontation
with the catastrophe
of life,
right?
And,
but that has to be made personal,
you know,
so that,
that's one of yoga,
I would say,
deepest ideas,
is that the archetipal has to be
made personally in your own life.
And so you take the generic
pattern and you personalize it,
and then the infinite and the finite meat.
And that's the perfect combination.
And there's something about that that's,
well,
honorably profound I would say.
And,
and,
and as true as anything can be,
and I think people know this at the
very deep level because you do know when
you're struggling to go to sleep at night
and your conscience is bothering you
and you think through the
things that you did in the day,
in the week,
you'll take solace in the things that
you did that were noble and true and you,
and you can,
you can breathe a sigh of relief that
you're not completely corrupt and lost and
then you can sleep.
It's like everyone knows this.
Well,
we need to know it consciously,
right?
And that's part of the process,
making the archetypal personal and that,
that's part of what the religious
process is supposed to be about,
is to outline the,
the archetipal pattern and then to say,
look,
you have to meditate on this.
And you have to figure out how to make
it true in the confines of your own life.
And that gives,
see the reason that works I think is
because there's no doubt that your life is
tragic and there's no doubt that you have
a bilevel and element and that you'll
be touched by betrayal and
all those terrible things.
But there's a nobility about youtue and
that nobility might be sufficient to
transcend your limitations.
And I would say that your life is a
struggle to determine if that might be the
case.
And that's the act of faith.
And I also do believe I was asked today
by South African journalist if I'm the
ultimate pessimist or
the ultimate optimist,
no one.
I would say in some ways I
am the ultimate pessimist.
I know I think as much as I can
tolerate how terrible life can be,
but I do believe that the human spirit
can overcome that catastrophe and can
rise out of it.
And I think the universities are that
that idea expressed in stone and tradition
and it's a great idea.
Everyone needs the idea,
especially people who are young,
you know your life is,
you know that your life
is going to be difficult.
It's like no one can say,
well,
it's going to be easy.
But you might say,
well,
do you want it to be easy?
What's in it for you?
If it's easy,
well,
no,
you want it to be difficult and worthwhile
and you want to be the sort of person
that can manage that and
that's what you should be.
That's what you should be
encouraged to be at university.
And,
and that's what the universities are for.
So,
well that's the archetipal
and the personal,
I would say.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
[inaudible]
this will,
uh,
this will have to be our last question.
Go ahead,
sir.
In recent time,
uh,
I would probably identify the most recent
us election is the turning point for
this.
And that's,
I've seen that as an American citizen,
this is my first time living in Canada.
Um,
I've noticed that public discourse has
taken to elevate fascism as the ultimate
evil and maybe rightfully so.
You know,
there were many horrific things commit
by fascist states in the 20th century and
you see people,
you know,
like Facebook cover
photos like bash the past,
you see,
you let stickers on laptops,
this machine kills fascists.
It is,
you know,
there's this big backlash against
fascism and the horrors that it caused,
but in spite of that,
you don't see the same reaction to the
horrors and the genocide that were caused
by socialist and Communist
states in the 20th century.
Do not.
You see people who virtue signal endlessly
about how horrible the Holocaust was,
about how awful these things were.
And then just hand away the famine,
genocide of the Ukraine,
the great leap forward.
They think these things
are inconsequential or even
necessary sacrifices for the
rise of the greater good
of socialism or communism.
And I personally find that morally
reprehensible and I can't understand where
that,
where that comes in,
how you can stand there and be
so opposed to this genocide.
What say that this
genocide is somehow just,
oh,
it's not a problem.
And why do you think that?
How do you think that disconnect happens?
How do you think people can convince
themselves of that and why do you think
that happens?
It's a great question.
Um,
you know,
I have,
my house is covered with,
with art from the Soviet era and
I have a road of reasons for that.
Part of it is to remind
me of what happened.
Part of it is to watch the struggle
between the art and the propaganda on the
canvasses sort of in real time.
You know,
I'm very interested in that,
but I would never decorate
my house with Nazi Regalia,
you know,
and,
and you think,
well,
why is that exactly?
It's not like,
I don't know that that what happened
in the communist regimes was utterly
reprehensible.
Why is it,
and perhaps it's not acceptable to have,
you know,
socialist realist paintings in your house,
but it's certainly more acceptable or
it seems that way than to have paintings
from the Nazi era,
let's say.
So then you think,
well,
why is that exactly?
And I think,
you know,
back in 1918 at the door
and the Russian revolution,
when Europe was inflamed and in ruins
and the monarchical societies were
collapsing and the industrial revolution
was in full force and there were
terrible,
there was terrible poverty
and terrible inequality.
The dream of Universal Brotherhood
was a compelling dream.
The dream of egalitarianism and,
and,
and maybe,
maybe who knows how much of it was
motivated by genuine benevolence.
Some Middle East.
It's very difficult to see that the Nazi,
the Nazi phenomenon was ever
generated by any genuine benevolence.
That's very difficult to,
to make a case for.
Um,
so maybe you can forgive the,
the socialists,
the communists utopians a hundred years
ago because they didn't know what they
were getting in for.
People had warned them.
Dostoevsky warn the Nitro,
warn them.
But,
but still,
and then the other thing too
is the problem of inequality.
It's like the problem of inequality is
a real problem and it doesn't go away.
Like it's very difficult when you
walk down Bluer Street for example,
in Toronto and you see homeless people,
alcoholics and drug
addicts who are struggling.
And the mentally ill who are on the street
and they're in their little domain of
hell.
It's,
it's really difficult for that to not
tear at your heart strings and say,
well,
isn't the world and unjust
place or an unfair place,
which it is.
And so you can see the never ending
wellsprings of motivation to support the
oppressed.
And I think the fact that the Communists,
the communist dogma,
at least had that as part
of its initiating ethos is
partly what seems to make
it forgivable.
I also think it's
easier for people to identify
why fascism is wrong.
We can say,
look,
racial superiority,
nope.
Okay.
It's pretty simple,
right?
It's three words.
You can really get it,
but,
but equality of outcome,
it's like that's really wrong.
It's really wrong.
But it's not so obvious why,
right?
It isn't,
you can't just say equality of outcome,
know and have everyone clap
because it isn't as well.
And that's the thing.
It's really difficult to,
it's difficult to isolate the pathological
elements in radical left wing thought
because they're not self
evidently pathological.
Like there's this old cliche,
um,
from each,
according to his ability to
each according to his need.
It's like,
yeah,
that sounds pretty good.
We have needs.
It's like,
let's have them fulfilled
and well you have an ability,
well like manifested.
It's like,
well it doesn't work in practice in in
fact it's murderous in practice and it's
a great catastrophe in some sense
that it's murderous in practice.
So I just think it's maybe part of it is,
is just a hell of a lot harder
to learn why it's wrong.
That combined with,
you know,
the genuine outpouring of compassion for
the oppressed and [inaudible] which is
like who's for poverty?
No one.
Right.
And,
and inequality is a painful reality.
It's painful for everyone.
You know,
even people who are self
righteous about their,
their status,
let's say,
in,
in the depths of their soul.
The struggling of the fact of the
struggling still rips at them.
And so
it's a more difficult
lesson for us to learn.
So yeah.
[inaudible]
do those people lined up at the mics?
I sorry for leaving you hanging.
I'm sure we could go on all
night if we had the time.
Um,
but we must call this to a close.
I would like to
salute you
for your patients and your dedication
in the face of the noise from outside.
Very nicely done.
Hold on.
[inaudible]
as you,
uh,
as you no doubt are aware,
Professor Peterson has written
an international best seller.
It's called 12 rules for life.
There are some presale in
the hall now before you go,
let me just say this,
you have participated in what I would
consider to be an important step in the
life of this university and
for that we should thank you.
So thank you for coming and
thank you for your support.
[inaudible]
professor Peterson,
uh,
maybe the most important intellectual,
a voice in this country today and I
would like to thank him very much for
coming.
[inaudible]
great night.
Be Safe.
I just have,
sorry,
I just have one small thing to say.
Hold on.
I would,
I would very much like to stay and talk
with a bunch of you and I generally do
that,
but I can't do it today because I have
to go back to Toronto when I'm going to
Australia tomorrow.
So I don't,
I can't do that even
though I would like to,
so I have to run off and then I
have to drive back to Toronto and,
but despite that,
thank you very much for coming and
for being patient and all of that.
Yup.
Okay.
Why is
it
great
shame on Queens?
No freedom for hate speech.
He says he really,
really chosen where I'm at with him.
I've been looking at his voice that
we're looking at the protest points.
I'm not really sure.
Um,
I just think it's interesting that he's
drawing the sort of crowd and that,
you know,
what's happening here is happening.
I think that really says something
about participation at Queens.
We're here to protest
a Jordan Peterson Dean.
You give him the platform
at Cuny University.
Um,
Jordan Peterson,
aside from not knowing
what he's talking about,
these are a lot,
uh,
Pearson pension type.
It's not a discussion about which
topics do you like on pizza.
It's a discussion about which
people should be considered funeral,
which you lose your respect.
And that's not a debate
that can happen anywhere.
I love that they are here.
How did this,
this course he does.
They don't agree with what he
has to say so they're showing it.
But uh,
I have seen a lot of
people call to cancel.
They are showing the Daniel Walsh should
be ashamed of himself for allowing this
to happen.
And that I just think is wrong.
I don't know if it seems like we have a
lot of very angry people in here because
someone's expressing an idea different
than their own and here at a university,
I kind of thought that was.
Thank you.
Would you like one more Pepsi Cola?
I'm good.
Okay.
Same.
Those groups
sell
fresh
eggs.
It takes bravery to say of that.
It was only stuff to what guys?
Yeah,
they broke the fucking window.
I'll run in there.
Jesus Christ.
Crazy,
crazy.